qu-ce que vous m'avez ramené alors alors
le
sac alors ça vient d'où de Pologne de
Pologne faut pas juger faut pas juger
non je jugerai jamais le sac plastique
est toujours là quand
même ça m'a l'air
dégueulasse tu vas
goû c'est de la merde mais c'est des
cornichons cornichons
dégueulasses c'est quoi ils ont une
tte
déueulass mais tu les acheté où P c'est
ma grandmère grand son Périm trers c'est
tellement
gtil sur la tête de ma mère on va faire
un jeu on va faire un je ça pu tellement
on va faire un jeu le perdant va devoir
manger deux
cornichons
ça goûte là ça goûte
part n'orte
quoi je vous le dis on va faire un jeu
les gars le perd do manger deux
cornichons et il passa les plus sal
vacances de
Sal je vous dis je vous le dis on le
faitit
jeis qu' sont
pas arrête d' ah ben on va passer de
belles fêtes he avec ça je on va faire
on va on va faire allez vas-y alors je
vous le dis c'est très simple vas-y déjà
pour commencer va voir qui est qualifié
et qui ne l'est pas d'accord à chaque
fois les GIE c'est très simple je vais
mettre la balle dans une de mes mains ok
si vous avez pas la balle vous êtes vous
êtes non non vous êtes mort vous
continuez ah d'accord si vous avez la
balle vous êtes qualifié c'est bon vous
mangez pas les corniches Jean-Michel
main gauche main gauche donc ça là oui
fa tu es encore il faut trouver la balle
tu l'as pas trouvé donc c'est pas bon
toi tu es encore en L pour manger les
cornichons ben main gauche main gauche
donc laquelle cellel benï c'est bon moi
pasention Montiel main gauche main
gauche Montiel c'est
bon main droite main droite non vous
êtes encore en Liss moang j'ai les
cornichons l'habitude l'habitude bouffer
tes cornichant main gauche bien sûr
attends attends attends j'ai pas encore
fait ah pardon vas-y main gauche
toujours main gauche toujours
[Applaudissements]
oua
malheureusement Daniel ah j'ai pas de
[Rires]
chance le
hasard c'estme
main droite main droite main droite oh
non
Hugo main droite non pour l'instant il
reste Jean-Michel Paul ska Gilles Daniel
Hugo main gauche main gauche
[Applaudissements]
ça qume le destin c'est merveux est-ce
que tu peux sortir la main tout de
suite quoi maain droite main droite main
[Applaudissements]
droite droit main droite main droite
c'est bon non non c'est pas bon M droite
tu es encore dans le jeu tu es encore
dans le jeu attention on fait un deème
tour un deème tour parti JeanMichel je
choisis oui ça
va m gauche main
gauche à la
fin ma quoi main
gauche quelle main vous
voulez toujours la gauche toujours
gauche GAE toujours la
[Applaudissements]
gauche M droite main droite
c'est
droite Ron maain
gauche que toi qui é
SAÉ on aurait pu gagner du temps je
pense quand
[Applaudissements]
même pour la comme si tu avais
perdu encore dans le jeu
va manger les corn pakaa Gill Hugo Hugo
et Raymond attention maintenant va
passer à un autre jeu ah là plus plus
honnête c'est le jeu des chiffres ah ou
seuls les qualifiés vont faire un
chiffre avec leur main de 0 à 5 il
peuvent faire ça voilà jusqu'à 5 1 2 3 4
5 je vais compter je vais partir de
Jean-Michel la personne sur qui tombera
le chiffre sera sauvé ah d'accord vous
êtes encore donc jeanm Paula Gill 4 5
Hugo Hugo Ray Momo attention 3 2 1 top
top ça fait ça fait 1
3 7 11 15 18 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
15 16 17
[Applaudissements]
18 plus que
attention c'est
parti je pars un po 3 7 9 9 et 3 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11
[Applaudissements]
12êes plus
que
attention
3 5 + 4 9 + 3 12 12 + 2 14 on part de 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 tu es
sauvé pas moi je vais vomir on voit même
pas les cornichons on les voit même pas
moi j'ai déjà les rejets là on voit même
pas les cornichons car ils sont venus de
voiture de voiture en Pologne y a
l'essence
dedans non mais il y
aessence
une Mar noand je dis
hor je
sens il y en a un qui bouge il en a un
qui Bou pour cette
demiinale cette deminale l'UR pour cette
demi-finale on reprend le
jeu comme elle connaît et par galanterie
prendre la place
deend elle est
là là je t'explique tuavais dit que tu
jouais non
mais j'ai c'est un cadeau mais j'ai mais
j'ai ah oui c'est vrai
tu alors vas-y fais
maintenant ou vous avez voulu qu' joue
c'est le hasard c'est comme
[Applaudissements]
çalable un règlement c'est impable c'est
imparable
attention maintenant avec
attention gauche
[Rires]
gaucheoite pas
droite à
[Applaudissements]
to
encore une
chance attention si tu gag tu gages
c'est qui gag
cornichonsn
g droite a a
piquetoiain la finale là déjà avant même
d'avoir goûtées plus que de qui bouge et
on va jouer pour cette grande finale au
jeu des chiffres je vais partir d'
hasard total hasard total je vais partir
d' OK je vais commencer à compter avec
Hugo vous mettez un chiffre tous les
deux attention 3 2 1 top 1 1 2 3 4 5 tu
es sauvé c'est toi qui manges les
cor merci
[Applaudissements]
ouais Gigon
ganonon c'est ça pue quoi ça sent le
sent tellement vinaigre passé elle va
couper sa merde ça va la
CER oh là là mais moi j'en mange tout
tqu manges tout le temps tu vas don de
c'était deux hein alors si c'est deux a
dit deux non non il y a pas du tout à
moelle veut même pas manger les
cornichons de sa grand-mère alors ouais
moi si tu vomis j'ai ça oh la vache il y
a de la béchamelle il y a de la
béchamelle dans le truc mais elle elle
aime ça elle non non
non
elle provoque elle se délecte
hein pas faire pareil sa
grand-mère c'est trop bon ah c'est trop
bon ça pas l'air les chériesér un
nouveau jeu ah non non non non non
arrête viens de germer dans ma tête on
va jouer non pas à la courte paille mais
au court
[Applaudissements]
cornichon le plus petit cornichon devra
le manger non le plus gros non alors il
a raison je chante le plus gros dans
attention c'est
parti il y en a pas assez pour tout le
monde
[Applaudissements]
domageti dégueulasse bah vas-y ch tu
voas c'est pas
évident c'est horrible elle a pris un
[Rires]
pe miniub plus gros le plus gros le plus
gr le plus gros qui mange qu'il faut le
plus petit plus gros plus gros plus gros
père allez attention non mais tu
regardes pas oh là non non non non celui
de Jean-Michel pour l'instant il est
plus petit il est plus petit il est
plustit celui de c'est Jean-Michel pour
l'ANT plus gros c'est quoi c'est plus
gros plus gros qui doit manger ah mais
même ça cou et ça coule sur les doigts
c'est dégueulasse bah oui bah ça va pas
couler dans ton cul
principe toi je un malin franchement
laisse prendre son cornichon il est trop
malin laisse prendre son
cornichon j'ai un petit attendez
j'enlève dernier c'est
pour cornichon c'est Roco frère
du ça se joue entreir venir et
JeanMichel l'un à côté de l'autre arrête
frère c'est pas corn m don g aussi
non sur la ple tiens tiens mais on l'
tous touché avec nos mains on va pas
manger ça derrière ah c'est bon j'ai
géi c'est lui c'est alors je vais vous
dire je vais il sont execo
malheureusement tous les deux manger le
[Musique]
cornichon tout le monde l'a touché et
tout mais tout le monde l'a touché dans
le pot et
tout attention tu casses pas je te dis
j' a un autre fais gaffe he donnezi ça
je vais ledner à mes enfants ce
soir j'ai déjà mangé des trucs
dégueulasses mais là mais c'est horrible
et c'est ta grand-mère qui fait ça oui
il faut
[Applaudissements]
l'arrêter tu Manes de respect à tous les
Polonais tu manques de respect à tous
les Polonais dis me dis pas qu'ils sont
pas Périm si ils sont
Périm c'est le principe c'est comme ça
ça c'est le
principe principe de quoi
ILP
ché je teand je teand au téléspectateurs
on serit pas des petits
[Applaudissements]
pour des ufs c'est pour moi c'est cadeau
ché non mais c'est horrible c'est hor
c'est horrible l'EUR l'odeur est
horrible